mais regarde en ce qui concerne
circulation
nous avons prédit que dans les régions
identifiés comme des foyers soit
entrée autorisée ou
et l'enlèvement à l'exception de tout
spécifique et vrai que vous permettez ensuite
évalué de temps en temps bien sûr
dans les domaines concernés et que nous avons
identifiés comme foyers dont nous disposerons
aussi étaient vraiment déjà arrangés
la suspension de la
activités de travail à la fois sous la forme de
entreprises collectives qui, sous la forme de
des initiatives individuelles ont été organisées
même aux suspensions de manifestations
public de divers événements
la suspension des activités éducatives
didactique scolaire
[La musique]
notre objectif fondamental aussi
celle des dispositions du présent
décret et essayer de contenir isoler le
contagion à l'intérieur autant que possible
les districts des territoires essaient de tout faire
qu'est-ce qui est possible pour empêcher ça
ils peuvent sortir
les 76 personnes concernées sont cinq
régions surtout dans la région
lombardie nous avons le plus grand nombre de
54 personnes en Vénétie sont concernées 17
2 en Émilie-Romagne il y en a deux dans le Latium
le couple de touristes chinois qu'ils sont
hospitalisé à Spallanzani
Je peux prédire qu'il y aura des ministres
nous nous sommes mis d'accord sur la compétence mais c'est
du ministre des sports et du ministre
spatafora qui a déjà annoncé la
détermination à suspendre tout
événements sportifs qui sont
prévue demain dans le
Vénétie et Lombardie
et une enquête est en cours
mené une étude épidémiologique approfondie
par les autorités sanitaires locales avec
accompagnement des techniciens de l'institut
supérieur des soins de santé en plein accord e
qui a précisément pour but d'aller
reconstruire la chaine de transmission e
de toute évidence, ils examinent tous les
hypothèse et remise dans les prochaines
jours de pouvoir avoir des réponses
hypothèse du patient zéro et un petit-fils
c'était une des hypothèses qu'il n'a pas trouvé
cependant, confirmation après quelques investigations
[La musique]
pour le moment il n'y en a absolument pas
extrêmes sur une initiative de ce type
sans en tenir compte et là je ne m'attarderai pas dessus
de l'impact dévastateur sur le nôtre
économie qui aurait et personnellement la
ils veulent renverser
mais que voulons-nous faire de l'Italie
il n'y a pas de conditions
pourquoi on en arrive là
et nous voulons y arriver